quoique si nous bonjour à tous et si
johnny mathias et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue à kapatakan d'entrée de jeu
j'aimerais revenir rapidement sur le
sujet de ma dernière chronique ou est-ce
que je parlais de l'importance de
consommer la culture autochtone qui est
vrai et authentique
est ce que j'aimerais souligner c'est
notre récente initiative des mises de
l'avant par la commission développement
économique des premières nations en
partenariat avec l'artiste autochtone et
nationale b franck personnes qui ont
créé un logo à l'effigié d'un ours qui
permettra des temps d'identifier les
services et les produits autochtones
authentique donc félicitations pour
cette belle initiative qui permettra de
mettre en lumière donc le travail des
artisans les artisans et des
entrepreneurs autochtones
cette semaine dans mon reportage mais
moi j'avais envie de vous parler de
développement économique
ça a été un peu le gros sujet le
dernièrement puisque les 25 et 26
novembre dernier a eu lieu le grand
cercle économique des peuples
autochtones et du québec ici à montréal
donc lors de cette rencontre l'homme est
guéri des questions de développement
économique
chez les premières nations chez les
peuples autochtones et aussi de comment
est-ce qu'on peut le faire mieux que ce
développement économique là et comment
être inclusive davantage
et moi cette semaine ce dont j'avais
envie de parler avec vous c'est surtout
des enjeux qui sont liées au
développement économique il faut savoir
le dans un premier temps que le
développement économique il est
étroitement liée à la notion
d'autodétermination des peuples
autochtones faut savoir que
la principale source de financement des
gouvernements autochtones provient donc
d' enveloppe
qui viennent du gouvernement fédéral et
du gouvernement provincial un petit peu
le du gouvernement provincial qui
viennent financer certains services et
certains programmes dans les communautés
autochtones et dans les gouvernements
autochtones donc par contre faut savoir
que ces enveloppes budgétaires l'homme
est souvent et vient accompagné de
certaines restrictions donc et viennent
elles doivent être dépensés d'une
certaine façon dans un certain cadre il
des fois mais ça fait en sorte que
certains besoins mais qui sont pas
comblés au sein des communautés puis au
sein des gouvernements des premières
nations ce qui devient intéressant ce
moment là mais c'est de développer des
fonds autonome de générer des
fontenelles qui vont permis qui vont
permettre au gouvernement autochtone de
dépenser cet argent là de la façon dont
elle souhaite donc à ce moment-là au
pouvoir peut-être venir combler des
besoins qui sont pas couverts par les
angles budget ans qui vient du fédéral
et du provincial
une des façons de générer des fonds
internautes autonome mais c'est d'avoir
une certaine forme de de redevances par
rapport à l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles qui sont faits sur les
territoires autochtones et sauce ça
devient un enjeu majeur donc les
communautés autochtones le disent depuis
plusieurs années elles ont passé leur
mot à dire sur la façon dont leur
territoire est exploité et en plus mais
russell et reçoivent pas des redevances
adéquats par rapport à l'exploitation
des ressources naturelles qui sont faits
sur leur territoire donc le premier
enjeu c'est d'avoir cette reconnaissance
des droits des premières nations sur les
territoires ancestraux et de
deuxièmement bête d'avoir des redevances
qui sont liés à l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles
donc ça c'est une façon de générer des
fonds autonome pour les premières
nations par contre au cours des
dernières années on a vu mettre une
certaine certains enjeux liés à
l'exploitation de ses ressources
naturelles là on a vu on a vu naître le
certains mouvements
puis l'exemple des watts ou et n en
étant un bon là où est ce qu'on a vu une
opposition entre les gouvernements de la
nation qui disait ben nous on a envie de
permettre aux familles par le club de
traverser notre territoire en échange de
redevances
donc de redevances quand même important
que la d'argent qui vont pouvoir être
réinvestis au sein de la nation puis de
l'autre côté on avait des chefs
traditionnels qui peut s'opposer à la
mise en place de ceux de ce pipeline le
de ce projet de léo dieu en disant bien
même si ça génère des fonds autonomes
mais ça fait en sorte qu' on peut
morcelé notre territoire puis on veut on
va complètement à l'encontre de nos
valeurs qui sont celles de la protection
de l'environnement en trop et cet
exemple là c'en est un qui disent ça
fait longtemps que ça dure je veux dire
c'était en place avant qu'on en parle en
2026 est encore d'actualité aujourd'hui
mais même plus près de chez nous au sein
de la nation abénaquise mais on a vu une
récente opposition le citoyenne par
rapport à un projet
un projet d'implantation d'une usine de
transformation de produits chimiques au
sein de la communauté les gens de la
population se sont dit mais ça vaut pop
c'est pas un ça respecte pas nos valeurs
autochtones de dire que nous on a envie
de protéger l'environnement de dire
qu'ils ont on veut mettre en place une
usine qui transforme des produits
chimiques en échange de redevances non
aujourd'hui les communautés autochtones
et se retrouve un peu entre l'arbre et
les corses à devoir se dire mais on a
envie de générer des fonds autonomes on
a envie de d'avoir l'argent puis des
redevances par rapport à l'exploitation
des ressources qui sont faits sur nos
territoires mais dans un sens on est
aussi des gardiens de ce territoire là
donc commun comment favoriser un bon
développement économique tout en
respectant nos valeurs qui nous sont
chères mais ça aussi c'est une très
bonne question que j'ai pas
nécessairement les réponses le mais
c'est pas facile aujourd'hui de devoir
faire ça puis je pense qu'une des
solutions bc d'avoir d'abord une plus
grande implication des autochtones dans
ses projets le je veux dire on
soit par contre pas de mensonge le
domaine matin on n'arrêtera pas
l'exploitation minière on n'enlèvera pas
des branches qui sont en territoire on
va pas arrêter l'exploitation forestière
par contre ce qu'on peut faire c'est
avoir une plus grande implication dans
ces projets là puis de dire que ben les
projets on va essayer de faire en sorte
qu'ils ont qu'ils aient le moins grand
impact possible sur nos écosystèmes sur
nos territoires puisque c'est pas parce
que on exploite les ressources
naturelles que on doit le faire
d'une façon qui respecte pas nos façons
de faire traditionnels on sait le no15
renouvelle les exploiter à une certaine
façon des ressources naturelles il
coupait du bois pour ce faire des abris
pour se chauffer on tuer des animaux
pour se nourrir par contre cet effet
dans le respect et s'était fait dans le
respect de la capacité des ressources à
ce jeu à se régénérer également je pense
que d'apporter cette perspective
autochtone dans dans la façon dont on
exploite les territoires mais ce serait
bénéfique autant pour les premières
nations que pour les populations à dos
allochtone également parce que ces
territoires urbains ont départagé les
territoires qui appartiennent aux
premières nations qui sont des
territoires ancestraux mais aujourd'hui
le ces territoires l'os et des lieux des
changes puis s'est ténu de partage entre
nos différentes nations et ce qu'il faut
aussi retenir mais c'est que il faut
diversifier le développement économique
des premières nations il faut se dire
que ça pense pas juste par
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
mais ça ça peut aussi se faire de toute
façon que par que de cette façon là
justement donc il faut générer des
opportunités de développement
économiques qui sont diversifiées pour
venir répondre à différents besoins on a
des artisans des artisans des
entrepreneurs qui sont excellents dans
nos communautés puis humain il faut les
mettre de l'avant aussi qu'il faut
mettre de l'avant leurs savoir faire et
leurs connaissances puis de dire que eux
mais ils peuvent aussi contribuer au
développement économique de leur nation
donc c'est un peu les réflexions que
j'avais à vous partager aujourd'hui
je suis curieux de savoir qu'est ce que
vous en pensez si vous avez les pistes
de solution peut être partagé donc sur
ce je vous souhaite une excellente
semaine et je vous dis à bientôt points
pour une autre portage